EUGENIA ROCHE: Hi.
My name is a Eugenia Roche.
I am coming on seven years next
Monday, March 17 at Google.
I am an account manager on our
sales side of the business.
I work on AdWords.
I work in media
and entertainment.
And I primarily work
with publishing clients.
So the scope of our
publishing clients
is everything from books
to magazines to, right now,
some pure play digital
players in the digital space.
Prior to coming to Google,
I worked at Conde Nast.
I was there for about
2 and 1/2 years.
I also spent some time
interning there and also worked
at a brokerage firm
on Wall Street.
The majority of
my time, actually,
though-- when I was thinking
about it, in my young adult
life-- was actually and has
been working with publishers,
even though I work at Google.
I have two kids, ages
four and almost six,
three step kids--
12, 17, and 19.
In addition to a full time
job, I facilitate a program
through our G2G
People Dev program
called Foundations
of Leadership.
G2G is an abbreviation
for, "Googler to Googler."
It's a program which enables
Googlers to teach, share,
and learn from one another.
We have traditional programs
like Foundations of Leadership,
which I will talk about in
greater detail, Managing
Your Energy, Presenting
With Charisma.
We have programs like
Teach Your Own Stuff.
So if you are an
expert in martial arts,
you can create a program and
come and teach it to your peers
here at Google.
We also have Engineering,
taught by engineers.
And we have language programs.
So there's quite a bit
of Google to Googler
knowledge that's shared
through this G2G program.
I took Foundations of
Leadership in 2011.
And I was inspired
to take the program
after I'd come back
from maternity leave.
I had been out on my
second maternity leave.
I came back.
And change is constant
at this company.
And I came back.
I had a new team lead.
I was on a new team.
And though I was
working with publishers,
they threw in some
cable folks who
kept talking to me about GRPs.
I had no idea what
they talking about.
The nice thing is that some
of these cable companies,
like Nat Geo, fortunately
had magazines.
So I still understood
how to speak their speak.
So the Foundations
of Leadership program
is a five week,
self-paced course.
And it provided a fair
amount of opportunity
for me to reflect on where
I was, where I wanted to be,
what was I looking for.
And it allowed me
to take some control
over a lot of the
changes that felt
like were just pushed on me.
So I have since, though, taken
on an additional leadership
role in facilitating the course.
And I've been doing that
for the last two years.
When the opportunity arose,
I raised my hand and said,
it's something
I'd love to learn.
I would love to be able to help
other Googlers who were once
in my position get through
that change and that tough time
and not feel like they suffered
because they didn't have
the facilities or the
resources to take advantage
of turning that around.
Facilitation and
just being a part
of this program has enabled
me to develop confidence
in the classroom.
I have also developed a
tremendous amount of confidence
in meetings.
So in my real job, I was
recently at a meeting
at Time Inc. I had 10
executives in the room.
It was a
three-hour-long meeting.
95% of the content was delivered
and presented by myself
and put together that way.
And I really think FLT--
Foundations of Leadership--
was a critical
foundation, so to speak,
of being able to do that.
So as I noted, I'm
on M&E, which stands
for media and entertainment.
And we work with publishers.
I love books.
I love to learn.
I was a double major--
English and Political
Science-- at Lehigh University.
Anyone from Lehigh?
Good engineering school.
I was not an engineer.
[LAUGHS] So I love to read.
I love to learn.
I was a double major.
I read a lot.
And as I've told you about my
background, my current story,
my reading time
these days is finite.
I have to be selective.
So the books up
here are from one
of our partners, Random House.
So I read, "Fifty
Shades," so that I
get the pop culture side of me.
Because I'm in my
mid 30s, I'm starting
to feel a little
bit out of the loop.
"Gone Girl"-- a bunch
of gals in my team,
we did this for
a team book club.
Eric Schmidt, "The New
Digital Age"-- yes, I
am trying to read it.
And, "The Parent
Backpack," I recently read.
It was my daughter
started kindergarten.
And I had no idea.
I have five kids, but I
didn't know what I need to do,
what my role as a parent
should and would look like.
And then, "The
Berenstain Bears."
So as you can imagine,
because I have little kids,
I spend probably
more of my evenings
reading to them than to myself.
And actually, last month was
the Race To Read program.
Being competitive, I thought,
why read one book at night?
Let's read four.
So we read a lot.
And, "The Berenstain
Bears," are in the lineup
almost all the time.
And earlier this
week-- actually,
as I was preparing
for today, we were
reading, "The Berenstain
Bears and the Truth."
So I don't know how many
of you recently read it.
Maybe you need to be
reminded about what happens.
The picture gives a lot away.
But the kids are home.
And it was good for my kids.
The kids were home, bored,
looking for something to do.
They play soccer.
Oops, they knock over a lamp.
Well, just like any kid,
they see Mama coming home.
And they think, we
have to cover it up.
So they cover it up.
And they tell a lie.
And that lie really takes shape
in a larger than anticipated
way.
And Momma, being Momma,
gets upset with the kids.
And she tells them, I'm not
even upset the you lied--
or that the lamp broke, rather.
Because the lamp can be
put back together again.
We can buy a new lamp.
I'm upset because you lied.
And my bears, whom
I've always trusted,
didn't tell me the truth.
And the bottom line is that kids
will be kids and things happen.
But in the end,
trust is something
that you can't put back
together again very
easily once it's broke it.
So I'm currently
facilitating-- just
wrapped up a five-week class.
And the week prior, we had
talked about teaming and trust,
and how trust is the foundation
of any successful team
and any successful
relationship, for that matter.
So here I am reading
about bears to my kids
and thinking about trust.
And I think Jan and
Stan Berenstain,
just like we at Google, knew
that leadership can be taught.
So here, Ben Franklin
says, "Being ignorant
is not so much a shame, as
being unwilling to learn."
But it really starts with the
ability and the willingness
here at Google to learn.
Adult learning, as
you can imagine,
is very different than
academic learning.
Participants at this
company are hand raisers.
Foundations of Leadership
fills up in less than a day.
That is how much people
want to learn here.
Programs are constantly
being developed.
And our programs
are not mandatory.
They're researched.
They're crafted.
There's a lot of
thought put into them.
They're designed to
educate and inspire.
And thinking about
crisis response,
our products are meant to
connect users to information,
right?
And Google-- Google
it, did you Google it?
It's now a word, right?
In common language.
And frankly, a lot of our
publishers whom I work with
are a critical part
of that ecosystem.
Because without content,
without information,
you wouldn't have
access to any of that.
So think about how you obtain
knowledge and information.
It's through
resources and channels
that connect you to it.
And it's a fundamental
part of our democracy.
So what I love about Google to
Google programs and Foundations
of Leadership is
that we are further
shaping the learning and
development of Googlers,
because we are connecting
our peers to content
about leadership.
I personally am continuing
to aid in their development
and working with them
on a program that
allows them to tap into
experience and relationships
and bring that to the workplace.
So what is leadership?
How many people
in this room think
that you have to be a manager to
be in a position of leadership.
I know I heard that
question before,
which was, how do
you manage your team?
Right?
So we just assume
because someone's here
talking about something, we're
in a position of management.
Or maybe management was just
misplaced for leadership.
So I love that the class
actually does just that.
We try to break down the
wall between leadership
and management.
Sure, some leaders are managers.
But the first
thing to understand
is that an organization,
especially a company
like Google, we need both
managers and leaders.
And they're not the same.
In times of war,
think about crisis.
You really need leaders.
In times of peace,
you need managers.
Both have a place.
So we go back to the
fundamentals at Google, here.
And we think about
Foundation of Leadership
just in a very basic sense.
So what is leadership?
Why is it different
than management?
Can you be a leader
and not a manager?
And the answer is absolutely.
Through a self-guided
process of understanding,
you can discover that we're
not actually even talking
about traditional leadership.
Has anyone recently
read, "The Times"?
There was an article about
getting hired at Google.
I know you're not
being recruited.
And our VP of HR, Laszlo
Bock, actually said,
we're not talking about
traditional leadership.
We're not talking about being
the president of the chess club
or vice president of sales.
We're talking about
emergent leadership,
leadership like when
faced with a crisis
or you're the leader of
a team, what do you do?
Do you step in and
lead and take action?
And then at times when it's
appropriate to step back,
do you do just that?
Leadership requires
an understanding
of your values, your beliefs,
having a biased action,
and taking initiative.
So the last class,
I asked the group
in one of our
debrief sessions, I
said, can someone
give me an example
of taking initiative recently?
And it was like crickets.
It often is at the
opening of the class.
No one wants to share.
And so finally, one of
the gals raised her hand.
And she said, I gave
up on a project.
Now, you're thinking,
why is that initiative
and why is that taking
leadership, right?
What the truth was is that
it was taking up time.
It was taking up resources.
It wasn't going in the same
direction as other priorities.
It just simply was a waste
of her personal resources.
But letting it go
felt really good.
And she was willing to
share that with the group.
And I was actually
struck by the fact
that, wow, that
was a big admission
for you, or for anyone
for that matter.
And the truth is leadership
requires initiative.
It requires optimism,
and requires
a fair amount of failure.
So there are a lot of
examples of leaders in history
who have failed and
continued to succeed.
But I think the most salient
example for this room
is Steve Jobs.
Steve Jobs was the
best at failing.
He got fired from
his own company.
You could not pick
up an editorial piece
when he passed away that did
not highlight his failure as
much as his success.
But his failure led him
to his next journey.
And he even credits
that time in his life
as the most creative
period for him
because he was
forced to let it go.
So think different.
That's what Apple asks us to do.
When I first came to Google,
one of the first questions
I got was, how well do
you deal with change?
And I was single.
I didn't have kids.
I thought, yeah.
I can deal with change.
Bring it on.
I worked at Conde
Nast, which was
a company that constantly
underwent change.
I started in January.
By March, I had a new publisher.
By June, I had a new role.
Change was constant.
It was often in
the form of a memo.
But it was somewhat refreshing.
It always felt like, OK, so
something's going to happen.
That means that we're
moving in some direction.
There's some upside to this.
We're trying to think different.
And then in the summer
of 2006, our publisher
at the time-- who I
still am friends with.
And I think he's a tremendous
leader and manager.
He bought into our
offsite, our sales meeting,
one of his managers, someone
from the leadership, Mitch Fox.
And he came in and
delivered this discussion,
this talk about our business
and the future of our business.
Now, it's 2006.
We're pitching a program as
part of our marketing project,
Snap, Save, Send.
You snapped a picture
in the magazine.
You saved it.
And you sent it.
That was revolutionary.
It was interesting
how at that time
we thought we knew
that mobile was next.
But we didn't even
really have the foresight
to see where it was going today.
But Mitch did.
And he challenged us
to think different,
to act as leaders
of our business,
and to think different.
He actually was
telling us something
that was going to
change our lives.
And he closed with the
1984 Mac commercial.
So just by a show of
hands, anyone ever see it?
Do you even know what
I'm talking about?
All right, cool.
A few people do.
I was five in '84.
So I hadn't seen it.
But I'm going to
share it with you
at this time for those
who have not seen it.
LEADER: "Today we celebrate
the first glorious anniversary
of the Information
Purification Directives.
We have created
for the first time
in all history a garden
of pure ideology,
where each worker
may bloom, secure
from the pests of any
contradictory thoughts.
Our Unification of
Thoughts is more powerful
a weapon than any
fleet or army on Earth.
"We are one people with one
whim, one resolve, one case.
Our enemies shall talk
themselves to death.
And we will bury them
with their own confusion.
We shall prevail." [EXPLOSION]
EUGENIA ROCHE: Give me a minute.
Whoops.
Return to full screen.
There we go.
All righty.
So I admittedly was like
those guys in the front row.
Like, oh my god.
I had never seen
a video like that.
I had actually
never seen some one
in the leadership at Conde
Nast come and talk to us.
It was always, like
I said, literally
delivered-- any change,
any inspirations
was in a memo, an email.
And I was totally taken aback.
I actually was inspired.
And I remembered thinking
that, although this company is
changing on the inside,
it doesn't actually
feel like our
business is changing
as quickly on the outside.
It never left me that we
should think different
and that change in
a company is good.
Without changing,
you actually have
to question the status quo.
So that was summer of '06.
I came and joined
Google in March of '07.
I was inspired to take change.
That leader, Mitch Fox,
he left in early '08.
And fortunately
for the two of us,
we left before the
economic downturn in 2009.
At that time I was actually
their account manager.
So it was interesting to be here
on the other side of things.
And the company
was finally forced
to change on the outside.
It was no longer focused
on changing on the inside,
but actually changing
the direction
of their business
on the outside.
And we're at a time
of incredible change.
All the publishers
whom I'm working with,
they are trying
to do new things.
They are innovating.
What they were doing
yesterday is old.
And that's why the notion of
leadership is so important.
It's having a
solid understanding
of these principles that
has allowed me, personally,
to embrace changes.
Because if you
remember, I was going
through a tremendous
change when I finally
decided to take
Foundations of Leadership.
And it's particularly
at times when
things feel upside down
that these leadership
principles make the most sense.
So a new baby, a new
team, a new project--
it's having trust
in those around me,
my family, the leadership
here, and my colleagues, that
is fundamental.
With change comes an
opportunity to learn again.
And just this
quarter, I was tasked
with doing just that when I
was facilitating Foundations
of Leadership again.
And the program decided
to change the content
and asked if I
wanted to pilot it.
And because I was,
I guess, maybe one
of the more senior facilitators,
and I said sure, let's do it.
And I knew that I was
taking some risks.
I knew that I could fail.
I knew that when the
Googlers, who are opinionated,
give that feedback, it
may reflect really poorly
against me.
But I knew that if we didn't
try to change the program
and if we didn't try to
determine whether there was
a better way, we
would never know.
So being a part of that
change is uncomfortable.
It's scary.
But it's what we
do here at Google.
So leadership for me at
Google is biased action.
It's being open to change.
I agree with Laszlo.
It's knowing when to
take the lead, when
to seek and ask for support.
That's important.
Asking for help is an
important part of leadership.
And doing so
throughout each step,
it's humility, the
willingness to learn,
and the challenging
yourself to think different.
So I have two things in closing.
One-- it's a quick exercise.
And we do this in
Foundations of Leadership.
So I want you to
close your eyes.
Look at the ceiling.
Look down, left,
right, what have you.
And just take a minute and think
about a leader in your life.
How many people thought
of a business leader?
No hands, nice.
A politician?
A family member?
A teacher or coach?
A community leader?
Research shows that
when we are asked
who the most influential
leaders are in our life,
generally respondents
will answer predominantly
that family members, teachers,
and coaches are the most
influential.
Leadership is personal.
There is no definition
of leadership.
There is no right answer.
There are leaders around us
who are doing every day things.
People who are trying
to change systems,
change ways things are
done, create something new,
and these leaders are
just like you and me.
Because the best leaders
are the best learners.
Yes, leadership can be taught
to those who want to learn.
And we all have the
ability to lead.
So I will close
with a little video
around leadership at Google and
what it looks like for others,
as well.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1:
Leadership to me
is doing something
that you know is write,
even when others aren't as sure.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2:
So leadership to me
is three things-- communicating
effectively, building
relationships, and
making decisions.
FEMALE SPEAKER 3: Aligning your
passions with the right people
and finding a purpose together.
FEMALE SPEAKER 4:
Leadership at Google to me
is about having the
passion and the courage
to make a difference for the
things that you believe in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EUGENIA ROCHE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
'Happy to answer any questions.
ANNA: Hi.
My name is Anna.
And I wanted to ask--
so in technology
it's really hard not to
only be a woman, because
of the percentage, but
also, like one of the ladies
were talking how they come from
not a traditional background--
so how do you
approach this better
when you have a room full of
very opinionated developers
and you're trying to not only
convince them to do something,
but convince them to do
something they don't really
want?
Or--
EUGENIA ROCHE: That's
a good question.
ANNA: --like something
different, something new.
EUGENIA ROCHE: So can
you give me an example?
ANNA: OK.
So if the company is very
backend developer-driven,
like a very traditional
approach, I'd say,
where developers
just have one role,
getting them to think different
sometimes is a challenge.
Trying a different approach
might be a challenge.
And being the only--
not necessarily leader,
but trying to lead this
effort can be a challenge.
EUGENIA ROCHE: Got it.
So that's where the biased
action thing, I think,
makes the most sense.
Or at least I had a personal
experience where-- so I
used to work on the
traditional side of ads
and worked at Conde Nast.
In fact, when I was leaving,
in HR they said to me,
what are you going to
go do, sell AdWords?
Like it was the
lowest-brow thing
I could possibly be doing,
leaving this glamorous magazine
to go here.
And so now I'm here a
few years down the road.
And Conde Nast is my client.
And I keep going in with
different team members who
want to sell them
a YouTube masthead.
And every time I'm
going in with my head
down because that's not
what they want to buy.
That's not what
they're interested in.
They're looking for a solution
to a business problem.
And we're not helping them.
So I actually did
something for my team.
I created a How Do Magazine
Publishers Make Money 101.
And I had my teammates,
after the fact, say to me,
oh my god, I had no idea.
They are now one of
our biggest clients
because we finally understood.
And my teammates who
actually pitch ideas to them
finally understood we have to
tap into what their business
problems are and solve them.
So I can't really speak from
an engineering perspective.
But I would say if you can
find a business problem
and attempt to address it
in a way that solves it,
I think you're in a
better place than trying
to push against something
that's unwilling to change.
AUDIENCE: Hello I'm
[? Elaina ?] Berry.
EUGENIA ROCHE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'll be your
second question, I guess.
So I deeply believe
in vulnerability
as being a core
exhibit of leadership.
And so I wonder if you
share that believe at Google
and whether you actively
train people on it
and you really push forward.
Do you look for
it in interviews?
Do you build that
culture around it?
Just a question.
EUGENIA ROCHE: Yeah.
So actually going back
to, "The Berenstain Bears
and the Truth," because that
was the Monday-- so my class
is on Wednesdays.
So I had Wednesday.
And then came Sunday or Monday,
we were reading, "The Truth."
And, "Trust," was
around teamwork
and how do you build trust.
And the bottom line
is you want to build
vulnerability-based trust.
If you want to look
up Patrick Lencioni,
we use a lot of his content.
He'd come to Google.
And so we had a video.
We had taped it one time.
And Googlers watch it.
But it's about being butt naked
and being completely honest.
We do a lot of things at
Google to develop trust.
We have opportunities
for Googlers
to have lunch with one another,
team events, off-sites.
So trust is really important.
Because everything we
do is usually on a team.
Even if you are the
manager of a team,
you're probably part
of a bigger team.
So teams are really,
really important here.
And the bottom line is you
can't have an effective team
if no one trusts one another.
And you need that
vulnerability-based trust.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious how you assess
the impact of the trainings.
EUGENIA ROCHE: How
do I asses that?
So feedback is asked for.
So I personally
get a score in it.
I can't remember--
I saw this once,
but there's something
like, teachers
take credit for
students who do well.
And there's some
psychology behind it.
But I honestly have seen people
in my class who have gone on
to do really incredible things.
I know Jackie Brown is here.
She's a lead recruiter.
She runs yoga.
I see her all the time.
Her name is always out
there doing these classes.
And I want to say she's probably
been doing it before FLT.
But I really started
seeing her-- and even
people I know say, oh, you're
going to Jackie's class.
So I think it's
assessed in part by how
we see people move on
and do other things.
Again, they're hand raisers.
So people who come into these
programs are already in a place
where they're looking to
be an agent of change.
Or they're looking
to take initiative.
They just need someone to
push them over the edge.
And they just need
the core principles
to help guide them
in that direction.
So it's not uncommon
to see people suddenly
on a promotion path or suddenly
be taking on a new project.
And the last quarter
of the content
I've piloted, one
of the things we did
was we tasked the group
with certain priorities
that we've identified
in the company
and asked them to lead and be
an agent of change against them.
One of the participants
in the class
is actually moving forward
with that on an internal thing
that we have around Google Gist.
And she said, I
don't know if it's
the intersection of the
program or my interest,
but it made me want to do it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PATRICE CAROL: Hi,
I'm Patrice Carol.
EUGENIA ROCHE: Hi.
PATRICE CAROL: So
my question was--
I've seen a lot of
culturally instilled problems
in women, for instance--
I mean problems
that women face
in their attitude.
For instance, seeing multiple
friends and coworkers
work really hard for an extra
year and be in frustration
rather than ask
for the promotion
or raise that a male counterpart
would have probably asked
for earlier.
So I was wondering if you
see any pitfalls and setbacks
to leadership that women in
particular face and what advice
you give them in your class?
EUGENIA ROCHE: So
that's a good question.
That's something
I struggle with.
The last two days I was
traveling with my stepdaughter
to visit colleges.
And when reflecting on
where she's going to go,
one of her decisions
may be to a school
that wasn't an original choice.
Because she said,
well, I didn't think
I was going to get in there.
And I said, why.
She didn't think she was
going to get in anywhere.
Right?
And that's the way women think.
And I'm trying to get
her to stop doing that.
This last class of
Foundations of Leadership
was pretty well balanced.
The last few
quarters, I noticed,
it was really heavy in men.
And I don't know why.
But I will say
that Google is very
conscientious around trying to
flip that around on its head.
We have a large percentage
of women in the company.
We devote a lot of
time and attention
around building our women.
Because they
shouldn't be just left
in the sidelines while their
men counterparts take off.
We're a growing company.
So there are growing pains.
But it is certainly something
that we're trying to address.
And I think in part
that's why I like
being a part of this program
and being part of the G2G.
Because I can help
shape that further.
But also standing up there
and saying, but I'm a woman,
and I'm going to take on
this challenge, hopefully
will motivate others.
Yeah, so that's the bottom line.
It's not something
that's overlooked.
I could put it that way.
PATRICE CAROL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I actually had a
very similar question to that.
It just has a slightly
different bend to it.
I was wondering, there do seem
to be pretty big differences
between the way guys
traditionally lead
and the way girls
traditionally lead.
And I was wondering,
you were giving
examples of all of these
different types of leadership.
How do you make that
apparent to a company?
It's not as easy
as saying, I was
president of the chess club.
I'm a good leader.
I was wondering, with these
new sorts of leaderships where
you don't have to necessarily
be a manager, how do you still
convey that to people, that
you have leadership skills?
It's just a different
type of leadership.
It might be a quieter
EUGENIA ROCHE: That's
a good question.
That's something I
think Laszlo should
have been asked as a
follow up in, "The Times."
Because frankly, I don't know.
When our leadership
is up here saying,
well, we're looking
for these qualities.
I don't actually
know if all the way
down here, on a
day to day level,
on the ground level,
how that's assessed.
I can say in terms of our
performance management,
at least on the sales
side, they recently
changed it so that you're
going to be evaluated more
around your
performance the things
that you're doing, as
opposed to your peers.
And I really wanted
something like that.
Because there are things
that I'm doing my peers
are not doing.
But yet my job
function is the thing
that I keep getting assessed
against them around.
And we're not the same.
So the company is
trying to change
and trying to identify areas
where people are speaking up,
where they are
taking initiative.
Frankly, I wouldn't
be here if I didn't
keep coming to different
things and saying, I do FLT,
and I'm passionate about this.
In part, it's because you have
to just keep putting yourself
out there and raising your hand.
And there are women that
will overshadow you.
Forget the men.
There are a lot of
women in this company.
Really, I think--
I could be wrong,
but I think there are more
women here than there are men.
At least that feels
like the way things are.
And we should support
one another, too.
So keep that in mind when
you think about women.
Because I think sometimes
women are not always
the best supporters
of one another.
Any other questions?
Yeah?
MALE SPEAKER: Last one.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I'm just curious, because I
come from a military background,
I work for the government.
I love everything
you're talking about
and all the initiatives
you're taking on
and the leadership
courses and everything.
I'm wondering if in private
industry and here in Google
you find the same type of
resistance I, personally,
or we find in a more traditional
environment like the military
and government.
EUGENIA ROCHE: So can
you define, "resistance,"
just so I understand.
AUDIENCE: Well, like when you're
creating all these programs,
like the G2G or when you're
offering the leadership course.
Was it just as
easy as saying, oh,
here is this leadership course.
And everybody goes,
yes, I want it.
Or do they openly
encourage this type of--
EUGENIA ROCHE: Openly
encourage, absolutely.
Like I said, there is
the Teach Your Own Stuff.
So if you have a skill
or trade or something
you want to share with
others-- literally,
there are knitting clubs.
There is someone who
can teach martial arts.
I have a girlfriend--
who is now facilitating,
but she was once in my class--
she goes to a writing club.
It's taught by someone else
who has a writing background.
So if you can get people
to-- again, I was out
visiting colleges--
if you have an idea
and you can get enough
people to be invested in it
or join you or do it, you
can find support and a way
to promote it.
So G2G is the avenue
to do just that.
And really, no
idea is a bad idea.
It's just making sure
that you get your idea out
there in front of others.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
EUGENIA ROCHE: All right.